alors ils répondent qu'en terminant
après tout les hauts et les bas de ta
vie on va faire une petite interview
open dames c'est normal le disque de toi
que tu préfères le morceau de toit si tu
devais emmener qu'un dans une île
déserte algérie de nos voir si belle en
ce miroir placé c'est les gens du nord
les gens nous n'en avons pas très disert
et celui que tu détestes celui qui
n'aime pas du tout une chanson que tu me
connais certainement pas puisque je la
déteste ça s'arrose
ah ouais ouais si grand beat de ma
carrière
le plus grand moment de ta vie quand
j'ai connu mon beau-père et le pire au
monde savait quand j'ai perdu mon frère
ce que tu préfères en toi je crois que
ce qui me sauve parce que j'ai des
défauts 1
mais ce qui me sauve moi c'est ma
sincérité ce que tu supportes pas chez
toi
certaines en certaine angoisse non
justifié ce que tu as de plus sexy en
toi mes yeux je sais on me l'a dit
qu'est ce que tu as de moins et fixer
mon poids
ça va là que ça va oui mais ya des hauts
et des bas et des hauts des bas là aussi
mais là ça va bien et savent le jogging
ça oui le sport 1 le sport c'est vrai
que tu coures 10 km par jour
oui c'est vrai oui mais absolument rien
tu cours ou au champ de mars
mais non ce que tu préfères un sexe
les fesses ouais mais ce qui dégoûte
ce qui dégoûte dans le sexe c'est
l'hygiène ce que tu préfères à la télé
ce que tu préfères la télé de toutes les
émissions de la télé tout le sport le
sport est ce que tu détestes à la télé
la démagogie il va être servi en actes
ça ne sert à rien de les dénoncer parce
qu'en face on peut pas les bégonias
l'histoire de la scène tu regrettes que
l'a5 ça soit terminé
oui oui je regrette pas ce que j'ai j'ai
participé au sauvetage
et puis j'ai pas réussi ça m'embête